when you chase money you lose always and
forever
even when you achieve the money
everybody gets hyped when I hide them
like this then they do it for four days
a week a month
nothing happens there like that people I
carry I hit up ID and all the
influencers like you told me nobody
responded I'm like how many like 130 I'm
like good there's about 9 million more
the motivation watch a top 10 with the
leave nation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten rules a success vol 16
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what you love maybe you actually
love playing video games more than
starting an app company when I was
growing up playing video games was a
waste of time
today I think we can all agree a
professional eSports superstar for the
next 50 years probably behind proper
football and basketball is going to be
the biggest athlete in our world this is
nothing you could see seven or ten years
ago you must you must you owe it to
yourself to make sure that you're
building a company around what you love
not because cryptocurrency is the
current fad when you chase money you
lose always and forever even when you
achieve the money this is how humans are
wired rule number two over-deliver my
great legacy in my aspiration to be
someone that gets written about like
Robin Hood is giving it for free like
the thing that I if somebody asked me
what are you most proud of
I'm literally giving away all my best
for free but I don't know what else to
say a lot of people that kind of look
like me build audience to the masses but
then try to sell to that audience right
here's the four thousand dollar ebook
here's the come to my mastermind what I
do is back to your analogy that's why I
thought of it too I do business with
Chase and Budweiser and Triple A List
celebrities but for the masses it's free
I'm obsessed with over-delivering it's
why I say yes to she's like this in the
first place the fact that I get one of
the emails I get a day and I get a lot
of them that says I was at I was
suicidal like wheels that's heavy
that Trump's anything I will ever do
professionally one one person telling
you that they were going to take their
life and that your videos and podcasts
made them not is disproportionate
greater then if I bought all 32 NFL
teams and I mean that rule number three
be patient
everybody gets hyped when I hide them
like this then they do it for four days
a week a month
nothing happens there like that did you
look carefully at the 2009 and 2010
tweets how much engagement they had yeah
did you or not you know that some of
those tweets only had two likes and a
share people forget what my 2009 and 10
looked like everybody starts with only
one like here's the tactical part you
put a ton of content eventually
something kind of goes viral and you
spend a load of money against it because
people prove that they gave rule number
four be practical please understand my
biggest truth here today which is if you
are not sharing your thoughts your
process your journey your progress to
achieving your goals the stories you
want to tell about your startup product
service if you are not communicating to
the world and if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them not what's
valuable to you when you communicate and
that is a very big point I'll say one
more time if you are not communicating
to the world and when you're
communicating if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them versus
what you're putting out for yourself you
are basically irrelevant in a 20-19
world as much as it may be difficult for
many in this room if you are not living
through here you are not known this is
the game if you are under estimating
this and when I say under estimating
this if you have not made a significant
commitment to producing content for the
one of seven apps or websites that 80%
of this entire region spends a
disproportionate amount of time
penetrating and listening and consuming
you are becoming vastly vastly
irrelevant also if you want to learn how
to be confident like Gary and other
entrepreneurs check out my 254 series
the link is in the description below and
it's free
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
rule number five take shots like Gary I
hit up I deemed all the influencers like
you told me nobody responded I'm like
how many they're like a hundred thirty
I'm like good there's about nine million
more no because that's not the way to
position it right because most people
want answer that because somebody who's
got an audience that's all they see I
would say how can I help you see where
I'm going
like like yo I with you like how can I
help you yes you do you have your time
you never know
d-roc didn't have any leverage do you
rock ask me four times and then finally
said yeah fine make me a video not even
that mindset and then this all happened
because of it that's real that's real
that's the story that's the story he has
to be four times I want to make a video
for you he was a video I wasn't making
content like that then and but it was in
my mind and by the four thumbs like you
know what okay okay
make me a free video show me here we are
now he's the the word that people you
like people literally say literally
affirms literally people like that my
dear ox name is Rick you know detox
attorney it's real and and you know what
I said this at the time to the Arrakis I
mean you're gonna impact people like you
know awesome it is for people that love
to do it to do it you me people wanted
to make documentaries their whole lives
yet only 74 people a year get to do them
and now 74,000 people you get to do it
all it takes is one person rule number
six know yourself I just don't care
about the money yeah like I'm fine
making 47 thousand a year and reading
all the comments on Instagram and
LinkedIn that I was a loser and lost at
all interested interested that's what
it'll be remembered for the end then I
gave a hell of a lot more than I took I
want to be I want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time because
entrepreneurship is what I do and I
think the way to do that is to a build
big businesses and exits and companies
and put the points on the board
right but who I am okay right yeah I
mean like like I want to inspire the
most entrepreneurs to be happy not just
successful okay like there's so many
people are gonna be unhappy making a
million a year that would have been
thrilled making six thirty
rule number seven hustle the reason
we're sitting here today is I decided
from 2007 to 2011 to spend four to eight
hours a day replying to people on
Twitter that weren't even talking to me
you could type in the hash the name of
that town and then go in an Instagram
and then go to places click it and see
every photo that's been posted in your
town in that town you can then go look
at the photo could be her at a goodwill
saying huge score
you could reply and say good 7 to 150 on
a stapler go girl
now all of a sudden she's just a normal
human she only gets 6 comments to begin
with she's like who's this man she
clicks she goes your bio is I sell homes
she's like cool nice guy I hope he's not
weird and she's out but the 97th person
that does that goes he seems nice goes
in the funnel you put out a good piece
of content like I'm gonna DM him I'm
thinking about selling my home what
people don't understand is how much work
I put to even begin the process of being
Who I am today 2007 2011 is a long time
ago for a lot of people that year I
decided to go on Twitter search and
anybody that talked about wine I jumped
in and talked to them how did I get here
hand-to-hand combat rule number eight
love the process to build a meaningful
company takes a very long time is very
difficult and more importantly what has
happened in the startup community all
those wonderful startups back there
everybody now is pandering to venture
capital or to raising capital not to
actually building a business every day
thank you
it's important and and thank you so much
for jumping on that it's important
because let me let me tell you why in
two thousand six seven eight nine I was
taking all of my money and investing in
Tumblr and Facebook and Twitter and uber
and all these things that I did very
well with and why over the last four
years I've invested very little very
carefully because there's a disconnect
right now and there's illusions of the
reality if you stand here or sit here
today and there is nothing that you
could think about other than building a
business because the process of building
a business is your happiness not what a
successful business allows you to buy
well then you're a purebred entrepreneur
rule number nine have humility and
perspective if you can have perspective
proper macro perspective and you can
have micro you know practitioner ship
you will be happy and win yeah I really
believe that yeah having the humility
and the audacity back to your
contradiction but yeah I mean that's how
I got to clouds and dirt you know
because I've always been fascinated by
that about me which is the things I'm
willing to do right now that are below
my pay grade
this podcast this is super scrutinized
by the people around me like why are you
doing this we don't have 15 minutes for
very important your letting money
opportunity VIPs why are you doing this
I don't know like intuitively when we
were talking I thought it was a good
idea and I want to I think you know in
my massive person you know perspective
giving back I look you're going to
leverage me being on this show for sure
and that makes me feel good that's me
giving back this is a bigger thing
giving you these 15 minutes than me
giving you $15,000 for your app sure for
me it's easier to write the check so so
for me
humility and like perspective like I
don't think I don't know how many very
busy people are running around knowing
that they need to put change into the
bucket of giving back in their time not
their money and rule number ten the last
one before a very special bonus tip is
stop caring what people think there is
nothing nothing more difficult than
navigating your life based on somebody
else's opinion you actually care about
what your dad or mom or grandma or
husband or wife or daughter or son is
gonna say about you if you do this thing
it doesn't matter what they think when
you're 92 and you're sitting there
you're not gonna give a [ __ ] about what
punk man 96 had to say or even when your
aunt had to say who's miserable because
she never got hers so she's trying to
keep you down negative people latch on
to positive people and try to seclude
them from the world because that's their
little energy in work I see it every day
in life I see it every day
it's just what it is
I hate how many people judge other
people without having all the context
every time you judge you make yourself
vulnerable 99.9% of people that you
judge or have opinions on you have no
idea what is actually happening in their
lives like you don't know what's going
on in somebody's home everybody sucks at
something right like we all have
shortcomings and for me it's like why
don't we just audit that like why don't
we just look at it that way
and be like all right well I'm good at
this but I'm not good at that like
everybody's so absolutely are you really
really really not gonna live your life
based on somebody's anonymous icon
feedback but you suck suck go do your
thing I'm not living a life where you
allow other people's judgment to dictate
your behavior now I've got a special
bonus tip from Gary and how to say yes
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's move from
just watching a video to taking action
in your life for business here we go
question number one whose opinion do you
need to stop caring about number two
what's the shot that you just need to
take and number three who can you
over-deliver for today yes yes okay
[Music]
well if you talk but my big thing is
just talk about your singular truth than
your uniqueness people may follow you
just for your ranching tips or because
your tire on your truck you need to
change and you videoed it I mean people
think people like I'm not interesting
and I'm like people are interesting if
you weren't interesting we wouldn't have
traffic
rubbernecking is completely based on you
know what a Yenta is not necessarily a
good you know it's more of a israeli
word necessarily than but like people
are interested in other people so you
don't have a whole lot to say about like
expertise like somebody who's been in
the business for 27 years that's her
advantage right but for now your
advantage is the documentation of trying
to make it your side hustle like if you
live streamed you're in taught somebody
in here is gonna lie dream an entire
open house where nobody shows up right
and right right and then one of those at
the right time is gonna go viral as
somebody who's persevering through
adversity chewbacca mom happens a lot
you just have to put yourself in a
position somebody decided to post a
photo of an egg you understand you
understand like everybody's saying no
you are all saying no for the audience
I never say now if I would have said no
for you I wouldn't have made a cartoon
photo post and realized you guys want
cartoon photo posts for me to those
comic posts I started posting in January
are outperforming my standard content
so what do you do you just post all
sorts of shave your beard good content I
mean it I mean it like and you live in a
part of the world that New Yorkers don't
get this is like there's you just never
know but everybody says no and I always
say yes that is literally the binary
difference and I'm willing to deal with
when it's a no because I don't care
about the judgment
if you want to see the interview that
Gary and I did together check the link
out right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there he's eating something at the
moment
witty eating Gary English peas I love
them so much with with the skin or it'll
snow